[Aplausos]
[Música]
mucha gente piensa que comprar cosas en
my express es como regalar dinero al
partido comunista chino leyendo algunos
medios da la impresión de que hay algo
así como una relación directa entre xi
jinping y las empresas chinas verdad
pues os equivocáis atentos
[Música]
china frena la salida a bolsa de group
una operación valorada en 37.000
millones de dólares citando grandes
problemas por si no lo sabéis antes
group es una empresa de servicios
financieros que forma parte del grupo de
alí babá y si alí babá es el grupo del
que forma parte aliexpress hablamos de
una de las empresas más grandes y más
famosas de toda china no sólo es una
tecnológica que compite mano a mano con
los grandes gigantes de silicon valley
además es una de las empresas chinas que
más cuota de mercado ha ganado en el
extranjero sin embargo las autoridades
chinas están poniendo toda clase de
pegas para que el grupo salga a bolsa
[Música]
incluso se llegó a rumorear sobre la
supuesta desaparición de su fundador el
archiconocido jackman desapareció
durante varios meses de la escena
pública tras dar un discurso muy
controvertido en shanghai en ese
discurso criticaba duramente los bancos
chinos pero tranquilos
jackman ha reaparecido y está sano y
salvo
ahora bien el gobierno chino sigue
frenando la salida a bolsa de su empresa
and financial así que la pregunta es qué
problema tiene china con su mayor
empresa tecnológica porque el gobierno
chino pone tantos problemas con que el
finantial salga a bolsa no se supone que
el partido comunista chino cuida a sus
empresarios para que se coman el mundo
hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas
pero antes vamos a ver un poco de
historia
[Música]
la banca ya no siempre gana en los
últimos 25 años la economía china ha
multiplicado su tamaño por precisamente
25 un crecimiento absolutamente
espectacular
[Música]
y claro con estos datos puede que
incluso lleguéis a olvidaros de lo más
elemental por muchos rascacielos luces
de neón y antenas de 5g que tengan china
sigue siendo un país comunista vale es
un comunismo a su manera pero incluso
mantienen planes quinquenales y como
buenos comunistas los principales bancos
de china pertenecen al estado sí es
cierto existen algunos bancos privados
pero son muy pequeños más de la mitad de
las finanzas chinas están en manos de
los grandes bancos estatales más
concretamente los llamados [ __ ] y yang y
si en español suena muy mal pero en
chino mandarín significa los cinco
grandes bancos esto se traduce en
realidad en una cosa los burócratas del
partido son quienes deciden en última
instancia a quién se presta el dinero
conclusión la prioridad de estos bancos
no es prestar a las familias oa las
pequeñas empresas sino a las empresas
estatales a todo esto hay que sumarle el
hecho de que las regulaciones bancarias
chinas son mucho más estrictas que las
europeas o los estadounidenses en otras
palabras que si eres una pequeña empresa
es casi imposible que un banco
presté dinero
para que os hagáis una idea menos de la
quinta parte de todas las empresas
chinas se financia con bancos por
comparar en un país como alemania o
españa una de cada tres empresas pide
préstamos a los bancos y eso explica
esas críticas de jackman que tanto han
dolido a los bancos chinos atentos
sabemos cambiar la mentalidad de casa de
empeño de las finanzas actuales y
confiar en el desarrollo de un sistema
basado en el crédito los bancos de hoy
siguen teniendo una mentalidad de casa
de empeños los avales y las garantías
son propias de las casas de empeño y os
preguntaréis si los bancos no dan
préstamos entonces quien presta dinero a
los chinos cómo se montan los pequeños
negocios en este país pues mediante
pequeños prestamistas que cobran
intereses altísimos muchos chinos se han
visto ahogados por deudas impagables y
así fue hasta que llegó and financial
efe es una empresa tecnológica
fue fundada establecida en china como un
servicio de depósito garantía para
generar confianza entre conservadores y
tenedores en línea desde su primera
transacción alipay ha crecido para
convertirse en la plataforma de pago
digital más grande del mundo pero ya sé
lo que estaréis pensando muchos and
financial alipay plataformas de pagos
digitales que es todo esto un banco
nuevo pues no es una empresa del grupo
alibaba y diréis pero algaba no se
dedicaba al comercio electrónico que
hacen ahora dando préstamos pues ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
banco de jackman y baba fue fundado en
1999 el principio era un portal que
conectaba a pequeños fabricantes chinos
con empresas extranjeras que les querían
comprar producción al por mayor después
pasaron a vender a consumidores finales
primero en el mercado chino con temor y
taobao y finalmente a todo el mundo con
aliexpress a día de hoy
alibaba maneja el 60 por ciento del
comercio electrónico de china y dominan
casi un tercio del ecommerce globales
la conocemos en el mundo entero por el
comercio electrónico pero en china es
mucho más en 2004 sacaron su propio
método de pagos alipay y pasarán a dar a
otros servicios financieros como
préstamos a pymes préstamos a
particulares y así es como nació una
empresa dentro del grupo and financial y
mis queridos amigos de visual política
aquí es donde empiezan los problemas
para alibaba porque comienza a ofrecer
servicios que tradicionalmente ofrecían
los bancos es algo que ya os hemos
contado varias veces en visual político
cuando hablamos de los servicios de
tecnología financiera
el famoso fintech antes los bancos
gestionaban toda tu relación con el
dinero ahora ya no ahora ya empresas
como transfer wise de giro o revolus un
fenómeno que está pasando en china en
europa y en general en todo el mundo
pero hay cosas en las que andan si él
está siendo realmente revolucionario una
de ellas es nueva
lali pay en la página de destinos de web
para los usuarios pueden elegir entre
una serie de fondos del mercado
monetario puede ajustar su configuración
para que todo el saldo de su cuenta de
lippi
se extraiga y se deposite directamente
el marco y mont
es un fondo monetario los money market
funds o fondos monetarios son un
instrumento financiero muy poco conocido
pero el funcionamiento es el siguiente
tú metes un dinero en yubá y ese dinero
se invierte en dar pequeños préstamos a
otras personas tú te llevas un interés
más alto que si me tiras tu dinero en un
depósito normal además lo puedes sacar
cuando quieras y aquí es cuando llega la
super ventaja en el caso de joe bao no
hay ningún mínimo
técnicamente puedes invertir si quieres
sólo un you one que es el equivalente a
15 céntimos de euros gracias a esto este
servicio se ha convertido en un
auténtico bombazo en china atentos
el vaho del grupo alibaba se convierte
en el fondo del mercado monetario más
grande del mundo hasta 270 mil millones
de dólares llegó a administrar lluevan
en otras palabras de andrew es una
auténtica revolución financiera y por
eso la salida a bolsa de esta empresa
iba a ser la más grande de la historia
tal cual como louis se esperaba que
venderían acciones por 37 mil millones
de dólares para que os hagáis una idea
la salida a bolsa de aramco la petrolera
de árabe saudí se saldó con ventas de
acciones por valor de sólo 29 mil
millones de dólares
sin embargo meses antes de sacar la
empresa a bolsa los reguladores
financieros chinos pusieron el freno
porque pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
las razones ideológicas además de huelva
o am ha seguido explorando las
posibilidades del fintech gestión de
patrimonios préstamos a pymes y toda
clase de servicios que os podáis
imaginar esto está suponiendo todo un
poquito para los bancos de china hay
estudios que aseguran que las firmas de
tecnología financiera se habrán comido
en menos de cinco años más del 40% de
las posibles comisiones por tarjetas de
china lo que supondría una pérdida anual
de alrededor de 60 mil millones de
dólares para los bancos
[Música]
pero no sólo eso este desplazamiento de
los usuarios desde los bancos estatales
hasta entidades fin te como an grup
supone que se estaría privatizando la
banca en china con todo lo que eso
implica para el partido comunista en
términos de pérdida de control sobre la
economía china porque controlar la banca
es controlar la economía así que la
reacción de las autoridades chinas ha
sido muy pero que muy contundente
[Música]
el presidente de china xi jinping se
ocupó personalmente de hundir la salida
a bolsa de and financial pero esperado
momento porque esta no es la única razón
no sólo hablamos de ideología sino
también de un juego político puro y
duro' atentos
[Música]
las razones políticas quién es el mayor
beneficiado de una exitosa salida a
bolsa pues los que ya tenían parte de la
propiedad de la empresa es decir los que
tengan acciones de and financial esperan
que su precio suba en el momento en el
que entran en el mercado de valores y
quienes están entre los mayores
inversores de esta empresa pues atentos
empresas de inversión ligadas al nieto
del ex presidente jiang zemin y el yerno
del ex miembro del politburó yang ching
ling iban a beneficiarse de la salida a
bolsa veréis una de las primeras
decisiones que tomo xi jinping nada más
llegar a presidente de chiná fue limpiar
el partido de corrupción dicho de otra
manera echar a todos los enemigos
políticos así es cómo terminó acaparando
el control total del partido pues bien
muchos de estos ex compañeros de partido
han probado suerte en el mundo de la
empresa de producirse esta salida a
bolsa no sólo serían millonarios sino
que además tendrían la propiedad de la
que podría convertirse en la mayor
entidad financiera del país sólo esto
explica que justo en el año 2020 es
cuando china tomó medidas como ésta
y sin lanzar una investigación
antimonopolio sobre alí babá es muy
curioso que comiencen justo esta
investigación en el año 2020 hace seis
años se podría justificar que alibaba
era un monopolio porque en aquel
entonces esta empresa suponía el 81 por
ciento de toda la facturación de
commerce en china sin embargo hoy en día
su cuota de mercado ha caído al 55% pero
esperad un momento porque no sólo
hablamos de política o ideología en
realidad hay una razón económica y
seamos honestos bastante legítima para
poner algún control and financial a que
me estoy refiriendo pues ahora mismo lo
vamos a ver
[Música]
las razones económicas podríamos decir
que and financial es un banco que no
tiene dinero ellos se limitan a hacer de
intermediarios tú pides un préstamo en
and financial y ellos te conectan con
pequeños prestamistas o directamente con
bancos actualmente la ley obliga a anza
y nan sial a proporcionar sólo el 2% de
cada préstamo y aquí es donde viene la
gran pregunta qué pasa si no devuelves
la deuda el problema no lo tendría el
intermediario sino el que te ha prestado
ese dinero en otras palabras que and
financial tiene muy pocos incentivos
para asegurarse de que sus clientes son
solventes más bien todo lo contrario su
objetivo es conseguir dar el máximo
número de préstamos posibles
[Música]
y cuál es el problema con todo esto pues
que fácilmente se podría desatar una
burbuja de préstamos una burbuja muy
parecida a la de la crisis de las
hipotecas sub-prime en otras palabras
and financial podría estar dispuesta a
prestar dinero a alguien que no es
solvente después podría agrupar deuda
buena y deuda mala en paquetes estos
paquetes se venderían a bancos o
inversores o suena de algo esta historia
y
[Música]
pues para evitar esto china ha propuesto
esta medida
china endurece las reglas de préstamos
en un golpe contra andy el grupo
empresarial de jackman en resumen lo que
los reguladores le piden al financial es
que ponga de su bolsillo el 30 por
ciento del dinero que da en préstamos de
esta forma la empresa tendría razones de
peso para asegurarse de que todos sus
clientes son solventes y si un 30 por
ciento es un número realmente alto para
que os hagáis una idea a los bancos de
la eurozona sólo se les exige un 1% de
reserva en otras palabras que con estas
nuevas regulaciones and financial tendrá
que volverse muchísimo más conservadora
con sus préstamos casi tanto como los
bancos tradicionales chinos por supuesto
con medidas como ésta podrían evitar una
crisis financiera como la gran crisis
financiera del 2008 pero por otro lado
están impidiendo que miles de pequeñas
empresas puedan financiarse
así que ahora la pregunta es para
vosotros creéis que china ha tomado una
buena decisión pensáis que este freno a
la financiera de alibaba está motivado
por la economía o que sólo es una
estrategia para que el partido comunista
chino mantenga su control sobre el país
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y como siempre no olvidéis
que aquí en visual político
sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas
así que suscribiros al canal y dadle a
la campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto
[Música]